[Music]
and of all places news submitted by the
Latino he oh that's a tiff has right now
uh-huh
I have to bring up the heats and get
your attention wait what do you will you
have Zika virus Fraggle no not Fraggle
prego prego
a woman's teen modeling photos ended up
being used on a very unfortunate product
kool-aid slash teen photo she was a teen
just like selling a dildo she was 15
not to teen nowhere guess as well I'm
just waiting I was waiting do your job
tip dad hurry up what you letting me do
my job that is so so [ __ ] hot is it
sexual
it is sexual is it a dildo your move
move no is it one of those fake vagina
pocket or pocket [ __ ] no there's
another name for them not a dildo [ __ ]
anal beads go back to dildo it's like in
the dildo vibrator vibrator vibrator
what about the vibrator it's like the
rabbit from Sex in the City this be
careful how you use it cuz it's really
like dangerous no now you're getting
further away dildo and just drop on your
clothes with the vibrator vibrators part
hi bear this massage toy she were done
guessing baby oh she posted on reddit
that time I modeled for a clipart
company at fifteen and ended up on dildo
batteries I'm like run days just regular
batteries you know what it looks like a
little bit it looks like a hipster
version of the villas like yeah
that's because I was gonna take those
candles because when Avenue 26 I thought
that they close down I believe tonight
we're gonna get the [ __ ] candles and
light it up for them yeah that was
really good
oh nice she's 15 right there that's kind
of old but not like the same person the
same person what are you talking about
32 I'm just saying this is a 32 32 this
looks like the same literally the same
personnel what are you trying to say the
17-year difference that didn't exist
between the difference of the photos is
she naked or 15 no she's wearing like a
little thing oh that same shooting so
they don't look like a 15 oh girl she's
32 yeah she looks younger she looked
older the whole time yeah the younger
self looks old but the older stuff looks
young right magic yeah I met in the
middle naughty and it's like sold in a
pack so the way she found out I'm Nadia
no that'd be a dope name that's crazy I
know she was a battery with Lauren like
a battery wrapped like her art was on it
I was thinking like an advertisement
this whole time she was on an
advertisement for like the same thing
they actually are the same company a
strip club it was for a local strip club
oh she doesn't have that look though
Jimmy she looks very wholesome and very
sweet or that's the love look like
that's just that niche demographic right
here and it's dildo batteries so it's
for girls
the batteries are for girls it's for
girls girls why is there specific
vibrator for girls because if they were
flashlight batteries then it would be
put it's called a flashlight
no I said [ __ ] chick or some Hulk
looking dude on a battery that's true
cuz they just look like double-a
batteries was she getting added if this
was not a dildo battery but just like a
Energizer battery and who the [ __ ] cares
the battery goes inside and you can't
even see it I am last longer
it's energized by sex that's why what
she goes in they get turned on
that's not a good job marketing did yeah
so she's saying that the clipart company
called Abel stock stick to dancing I
have never let that keep lying please
give me like the Big Brother wish he
never had I missed it
anyway if he made a joke that that's
what it was that was his joke nobody
laughed and you kept telling your story
and then he didn't that was that nobody
and it wasn't a hardcore laugh type of
joke it was more like it
acknowledged just play on words and
everybody seemed to do it it was great
you guys are in touch with your
authentic selves right now you need to
calm down nobody even knows what that
[ __ ] means nerd get in the car mr.
Rosas fool you came into a room full of
losers that's what happened to you
you're so elevated the fact that you
here you [ __ ] up I am who I surround
myself with
and I'm unfortunately proud of you guys
you're a piece of [ __ ] we are all pieces
of shite you're not you're not oh you're
you're literally the the jewel in the
piece of Dookie that people are trying
to fish you guys complimenting me feels
uncomfortable on this thing stick to the
regular routine you just move on the way
you want I know we want you to at least
know the true meaning
there's no way it looks like a spider
got onto me looking like a kid in it you
know I mean spider I was trying to make
up some new moves for you yeah he's an
innovator for you thank you thank you
you're back to the Noddy she missed it
we had repeated that's right maybe in a
whole snake in the hole in the ass
fisting fisting yeah you're never really
joke around about dancing cuz he
actually like got good yeah there you go
actually like is he on Bart's level
though above where's the rig on my head
where's the ring on my head yeah it
reminds me of that old hip-hop video
where it's like this is how black people
have swag with their arms in this is
party no you made it look way too swag I
know who's worse then you got too much
swag drunken hey is this better this is
what she wasn't and one and two and one
offer though yeah anyway she's saying
that I was messed up that they even let
her photos be used for anything approach
inappropriate because she was only 15
years old
so truth yes a women when they found out
about that local strip club ad or her
dad contacted his newspaper and happy
every move I like how her dad yeah was
he like 30 already her dad was probably
like oh my god that's my [ __ ]
daughter I'm about to go into the strip
club that's my [ __ ] daughter it's
just like his coworkers hey Bob in there
your daughter
you have you guys seem that the finale
episode of The Office where Meredith she
hires a stripper to come to Angela's
[ __ ] bachelorette party and it was
her son she started cheering on her son
no no don't do it this way do it this
way
that's what reminds me of how [ __ ]
weird did it was the actual kid too that
grew up from the early episodes oh yeah
the way she found out about the
batteries was that she got a message
from her ex-boyfriends roommate asking
if that was her in angel wings Oh cuz he
was replacing his girlfriend's vibrator
batteries you mean his ass vibrator but
why does it be specific batteries double
A's for that vibrator why can't me just
get regular baby of my own ones uh-huh
maybe it's like a bundle thing if you
get the vibrator and the batteries you
save on the batteries bet you he's
[ __ ] riding some dick it's gotta be
he's lying detective Joe we just come
down to the scene it comes onto the
scene fine amateurs he's gotta be right
so dick yeah I was replacing my
girlfriend's vibrator the other day cuz
she has me by the batteries
I never replaced a [ __ ] battery of
Jess's vibrator in my life maybe you're
just not a good boyfriend I'll buy her
batteries what [ __ ] unless that thing is
stuck and she needs my help
what is just didn't want you to reveal
she uses vibrators it's too bad could
it's done I think she said it on
publicly though I know I just heard that
[ __ ] went off when we went traveling the
whole suitcase is like she's taking the
batteries out yeah stupid really you
weren't in game for sure huh duh
Sheila took in the batteries out us you
were an ESL man
yeah that's right extra sexy language
yeah yeah should have took in the
batteries out there
sounds like King James Burchard why
sooth did you not take the battery out
it
why are they now taking out the bad
battery ative die vibrator to kiss 9
battery now he's having a stroke
everybody she was just in shock and
embarrassed she was in it so embarrassed
because of the situation somebody
thought we had my vibrator is very bit
but the situation I couldn't do anything
about it
with the old timing you taking out the
battery just [ __ ] over it with we're
not funny to him I'm laughing
[Music]